bonjour à tous bonjour michael après une
première entre des élections
sénatoriales sur l'antenne de public
sénat avec quatre duels deux sénateurs
nous sommes dans cette grande salle des
conférences qui est juste à côté de
l'hémicycle du sénat et le duel
d'aujourd'hui oppose l'ancien président
du sénat le sénateur ump gérard larcher
bonjour merci d'être avec nous face à
jean vincent placé
le président du groupe écologiste au
sénat bonjour à vous bonjour et dans le
contexte économique et politique que
nous connaissons et bien on va
s'interroger sur le rôle et la place du
sénat en 2014 à senna qui a souvent
était frondeur à ces derniers temps
notamment sur la réforme territoriale et
on posera évidemment la question à nos
invités est ce que le savoir si le
bicamérisme la française a encore un
avenir gérard larcher vous devez donc
été président du sénat vu le climat de
défiance envers la classe politique
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on peut encore se permettre
d'avoir un parlement frondeur et qui met
des bâtons dans les roues du
gouvernement le rôle du parlement c'est
de parlementer et donc de débattre
d'amendé d'enrichir de contrôler et
faire la loi
ce qui veut dire parfois défaire la loi
contrôler l'action du gouvernement et
tracer des perspectives et je dois dire
que le sénat parce que il l'est une
assemblée élue différemment parce
qu'elle est une assemblée dont les
pouvoirs ne sont pas identiques à
l'assemblée nationale fonde le principe
dhabi cameri sme qui n'est pas
totalement égal et ce principe du
bicamérisme autorise à cette forme
d'indépendance tout en plus j'aurais
ajouté que la réforme du quinquennat
fait que l'assemblée nationale est en
fait la réplique sismique de l'élection
présidentielle et que le sénat c'est
autre chose
nous avons donc qu'on soit dans la
majorité qu'on soit dans l'opposition
une responsabilité particulière
un espace de liberté une forme
d'indifférence qui me paraît devoir être
utilisé
c'est ça le bicamérisme à la française
c'est ça jean vincent placé la
spécificité du sénat par rapport à celle
de l'assemblée nationale où on a
l'impression que les parlementaires
l'aider
ut sont plus des parlementaires
godillots qui doivent être un peu plus
fidèle à la majorité au gouvernement et
voter les lois
le terme de dix ans je vous le laisse
perrine tarneaud mais vous avez présenté
le débat et c'est bien naturel sous la
forme d'un duel mais pour l'assurer
question du bicamérisme nous avons
beaucoup de points de convergence
nous écologistes nous sommes attachés à
des duettistes donc pas nous le savons
sont immobiles nous sommes attachés à la
question du bicamérisme je pense que
c'est extrêmement important qu'il y ait
deux chambres on voit que la vème
république et comme très autoritaire et
effectivement comme a depuis le
quinquennat l'élection législative avec
l'inversion du calendrier qui était
voulu d'ailleurs par les socialistes et
jospin on voit à peu près les méfaits
tout cela ça arrive les listes elles
résistent hâtive juste après l'élection
du président donc en gros le message
simple des élections initiative s'est il
faut donner une majorité au président
qu'est ce que ça donne ça donne pour les
deux premières années l'assemblée
on voit aujourd'hui des frondeurs et
c'est plutôt sympathique parce que c'est
normal qu'ils sont sympas c'est une
question de fronde
c'est une question de remettre le débat
au parlement les deux premières années
moi j'ai dit des choses on m'a dit ah
mais il compte s il ya des sujets
tactique et tout ça non là gérard
larcher a raison
le propre du parlementaire c'est de
parlementer c'est de faire des
propositions c'est critiquer parfois
assez de soutenir comme nous faisons
nous dans la majorité au moment des
budgets et sinon à quoi ça sert le
parlement et le rôle du sénat
c'est d'avoir une certaine distance sur
de nombreux sujets moi je salue le
travail des collègues dont je vois les
mecs carsalis aperçu jeudi par les
citoyens mais des gens les gens
effectivement rapidement une phrase
pense que justement le parlement ne fait
pas assez son rôle c'est exactement le
contraire la chaîne 2 du propos vous
avez pu tenir début de quelque chose de
paradoxal
aujourd'hui seuls les élus locaux ont la
confiance d'une majorité des citoyens et
j'allais dire dans un paysage un peu
désolé désastreux de la vie politique au
plan national les élus locaux conservent
la confiance
nous sommes les élus des élus locaux et
donc quelque part la voix des
territoires et c'est vraiment une de nos
responsabilités la représentation des
territoires et des citoyens qui vivent
et je pense qu'il ya là la marge de
reconquête d'une confiance et cette
confiance là à nous de la construire y
compris par l'attitude une puis deux
doit être la nôtre en matière de
construction il ay ay si les capacités
sur un certain nombre de dossiers
dégager des majorités des majorités sur
des projets sur des idées qui ne sont
pas dans une forme de clivage
automatique et qu'il serait commanderie
d'en faire la pédagogie on pourra
l'évoqué sur la réforme territoriale
mais il ya aussi des sujets moi je suis
un ancien ministre du travail très
sensible à la question de l'emploi de
l'emploi des jeunes
je suis certain qu ici nous pourrions
trouver des chemins ensemble sur un
sujet aussi important que le point des
jeunes peut pas satisfaire tous
gouvernements confondus
la chômage des jeunes ces deux fois et
demi le taux de chômage moyen national
voilà un enjeu que senna pourrait
prendre
on va justement parlé du sénat en 2014
on a été posé la question à des experts
de la constitution comment il voyait le
sénat en 2014 et vous allez marine vous
interpelle on commence par dominique
rousseau
il y avait cette expression le sénat de
ces deux chambres de l'assemblée de la
châtaigne bon on est au 21ème si la vie
on n'est plus au 19e siècle il faut
qu'aujourd'hui le sénat ne représente
pas le seigle et la châtaigne les
représente la métropole dans ces régions
représentent tout le dynamisme de la
fronde antinucléaire
si le sénat reste la chan
ceg de la châtaigne elle sera toujours
considérée comme une chambre suspecte
pendant sa légitimité
alors que les sénateurs s'empare très
vite de la question de la composition de
leur assemblée c'est le choc c'est seul
moyen pour assurer enfin la légitimité
du sénat dans les institutions
françaises
alors quand on écoutait dominique
rousseau gérard lâché 10 et s'était
complètement bidon jean vincent placé
vous allez commencer par jean vincent
placé moi nous sommes les élus de deux
des trois départements qui sont dans une
métropole très important sans doute une
des premières métropoles du monde qu'est
la région ile de france et on entend des
choses mais pardonnez moi de le dire
mais c'est en herbe elle a nommé jeudi
que c'est sûr a mené parce que la
question de métropole nous en sommes
emparés ces mêmes au sénat dans la loi
de 2010 que ce concept apparaît et c'est
aussi me semble-t-il une des
responsabilités du sénat que de
représenter les territoires la france de
ne pas répondre à nos matchs centrale
entre des métropoles attractives comme
ça c'est dit et vous demande jean
vincent placé et s'il faut pas amélioré
cette représentativité
détendu il faut bien sûr moi je suis en
plus il ya même un débat chez les
propres amis qui disent qu'il en soit il
faut supprimer le sénat soit il faut le
faire élire directement mais sur le fait
lire directement ça sert à rien d'avoir
eu si je suis attaché à ce pays
soyons le regarde et nous le relais des
collectivités
territoriales après évidemment il faut
plus se soient le relais des
collectivités territoriales de 1791
parce que nous sommes tout simplement en
2014 après moi ni voulons renforcer le
poids des régions je pense que ça
pourrait être un élément de d'accord
là-dessus entre nous le rôle des
métropoles la représentation des
conseils généraux on verra s'ils ont
vocation à être supprimées mais ça ne
peut plus être seulement les sénateurs
présidents de conseils généraux
on voit bien y compris les sourds
immobilisme que ça procure lorsqu'on
arrive à d'autres débats comme sur la
réforme territoriale qu'on vient de
vivre
et moi je suis très attaché aux communes
françaises dont je ne suis pas à
stigmatiser les élus formidable qui
dirigent des villes où il ya 100 150 à
mi temps ils font un travail de
proximité remarquable après qu'on a dit
ça lorsqu'on est y compris on le dit en
situation d'économies par rapport aux
finances publiques on peut plus avoir
une salle de sport ou une piscine dans
chaque canton c'est plus possible donc
il ya une forme de rationalisation à
voir et c'est pas la seule entrée à la
question de la rationalisation
économique mais tout de même
et donc il ya aujourd'hui je le dis un
déséquilibre de représentation au cedar
où effectivement les élus métropolitan
de la grande métropole parisienne lyon
marseille metz nous ne sommes pas non
nous ne sommes pas suffisamment
représentés moi je pense qu'il faudrait
trouver un équilibre plus réel entre
urbain périurbain et rural
même si j'entends bien que ce ne sont
pas seulement le critère du la
population qui doit jouer mais aussi la
représentation des territoires donc des
superficies en tant qu'écologiste su
particulièrement attentifs à la
représentation de la nature et des
forêts le bicamérisme il doit être
inégal et un des rôles du sénat c'est de
représenter le territoire le territoire
dans sa diversité de métropole et
d'outre-mer urbain et rural mais aussi
des territoires pauvres en démographie
et j'aurais simplement prendre l'exemple
du sénat américain
l'alaska 60 fois moins de population
et oui de la californie le même nombre
de sénateurs a le même nombre de
sénateurs a lâché
par état c'est un autre sujet il ya cinq
ans mais le critère démographique n'est
pas le seul critère est le critère de
représentation du territoire si ce qui
fait l'intérêt du bicamérisme c'est
logique qu'à l'assemblée nationale le
critère démographique l'emportent et
encore et il tempéré
quand on voit certains départements de
métropole et d'outre-mer ceci étant perd
donc je crois que nous jeter au visage
que des ratios mathématiques c'est raté
le rendez vous de votre caméra et je
suis l'élu d'un département d'un million
quatre cent mille habitants mais alors
il ya eu la fronde ces derniers temps
aussi au sénat contre la limitation du
cumul
on va écouter un autre sonore d'un
constitutionnaliste à lui il trouvait
que cette fronde contre le cumul était
légitime et agit de philippe blachère et
il estime que la limitation du cumul
remet en cause finalement la légitimité
du sénat on l'écoutait à titre personnel
je considère que si le sénat représente
les collectivités territoriales de la
république il n'y a pas lieu d'appliquer
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats aux
sénateurs si une réforme devait être
éventuellement être appliquée au sénat
ce serait peut-être d'introduire un peu
plus de proportionnelle pour permettre à
la pluralité des formations politiques
de pouvoir s'y exprimer monsieur le
sénateur comment envisagez-vous
d'exercer votre mandat si le cumul des
mandats s'applique à votre égard
autrement dit peut-on en france avoir un
sénat les sénateurs
or seule une vraie question jean vincent
placé eelv aux acquis son directeur
les lois sont mondiaux n'étaient pas
franchement de benoist il n'aurait pas
dû
mettre le conditionnel parce que ça va
s'appliquer en 2017 j'imagine que même
si le président changé en 2017 ce serait
compliqué d'aller contre le vent de
l'histoire en rétablissant le cumul donc
en septembre joint pour les députés en
septembre 2010 est pour les sénateurs il
faudra faire un choix
moi je le dis très simplement tout à la
fois le cumul de mandats en même temps
et le cumul dans le temps y compris moi
je suis même prêt à initier si j'ose
dire le passé parce que bon c'était
d'autres pratiques mais dans le futur on
ne fera plus peut-être plus de trois
mandats
on fera plus de cumul et très
sincèrement moi je les assume pas ce que
j'étais vice président aux transports la
région ile de france la loi ne m'obligez
pas n'oblige pas démissionner j'ai
démissionné de mon mandat exécutif j'ai
démissionné du syndicat des transports
d'île de france n'ont plus vraiment je
le regrette parce que c'était un de des
dossiers passionnants mais bon c'est
comme ça il faut aussi montrer la voie
et je dis joie je suis conseiller
régional de base si j'ose dire et quand
même mais mais d'une part s'apprend et
puis d'autre part qu'on est sénateur on
vous écoute beaucoup
moi je suis voilà sont trop mettre d'ego
dans cette histoire où de toute identité
quand on est sénateur jean a semblé
comme la région rhône
on écoute beaucoup non non je suis allé
partout y compris j'ai un petit débat
avec mes propres amis qui sont plutôt
attachés au mandat parlementaire
seul moi je suis pas du tout là dessus
je suis totalement favorable et même je
serais même pour inciter les
parlementaires à avoir au moins un
mandat local en particulier municipal et
effectivement je crois qu'on doit
trouver cet équilibre là au sénat parce
que c'est aussi j'ai important et je le
vois dans les débats la réforme
territoriale
l'expérience incontestablement j'avais
ancien maire d ancienne maison du
conseil général gérard la transmission
oui parce qu'il est content gérard
larcher à droite aura du macina droite
revient au pouvoir aura du mal à revenir
sur cette loi qui limite le court il a
bu il ya déjà des sénateurs qui ont
anticipé un qui soit ne se représente
pas aux sénatoriales où qui ont
abandonné leur mandat de maire c'est
notamment
cela les a ramenés dans les mémoires de
désir aussi fortement
je pense qu'ils exerçaient un autre
mandat local y compris exécutif
n'avaient rien dans tag nique avec
l'exercice du mandat parlementaire que
l'on limite l'exercice des
responsabilités que dans un souci de
transparence on le cadre
c'est quelque chose que je comprends et
partage mais damas en place et devient
le dire l'expérience de l'élu
territorial
mon expérience de maire j'ai été
conseiller régional et d'ailleurs
j'étais même été benjamin de cette
assemblée à une époque où on l'elysée au
suffrage universel indirect
et j'allais dire quelque chose qui me
permet d'éclairer me permet d'éclairer
mon mandat parlementaire miserait dire
une chose plus de proportionnelle
j'entendais 50% des sénateurs seront
élus au scrutin 75% 75% aujourd'hui en
je me projette sur 2017 ce sera 75 %
plus de proportionnelle
c'est une manière de compenser la
répartition territoriale
voilà pourquoi je suis pour le scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours pour les
départements qui ont une réalité
démographique
il ne reste plus que des bars avec pour
lorsque tu arrives tu à certains je suis
pour le scrutin
enfin parfaitement la jeunesse nous a un
peu bouleversé escompte que les
résultats des élections municipales sont
en train de déverser ce qui avait été
imaginé mode de scrutin généralement ils
reviennent rapidement au visage livide
petit on va aborder la réforme
territoriale qui était au coeur des
débats ces dernières semaines ici au
sénat on va voir avec cette enquête de
notre journaliste louis sybille combien
va rapporter la fusion des régions est
ce qui a beaucoup d'économie à l'ucl et
on regarde le sujet de louis sibyllin la
normandie deux régions côte à côte
l'union semble évidente dans le projet
de réforme territoriale
et pourtant en 2008 une étude a été
menée
pour savoir si cela baisserait les
dépenses publiques le constat est sans
appel la fusion coûterait 15 millions
d'euros et serait amorti en 20 ans
vous avez des économies d'échelle liées
à une mutualisation en fait d'un certain
nombre de travaux de fonction mais ces
économies d'échelle elles sont quand
même limité et cesse et c'est à dire que
si on prend l'exemple des lycées vous
avez des lycées dans basse normandie des
lycées en haute normandie vous n'allez
pas les regrouper pour faire des
économies d'échelle des économies bien
marginale
la réforme prévoit de diviser les
régions par deux au total le
gouvernement table sur une dizaine de
milliards d'euros d'ici cinq à dix ans
soit 5 % de la masse globale des
collectivités territoriales
chez les parlementaires de gauche ou de
droite personne n'y croit on nous dit je
fais une réforme pour simplifier les
structures territoriales et cela va
apporter des économies et qu'on ne soit
pas capable d'articuler clairement ces
économies de les chiffrer
quand on aura uniformiser gma militaires
des salariés sur huit ou dix
départements dans les nouvelles régions
on sera obligé de faire par le haut donc
au niveau des salariés dect et des
nouvelles collectivités
serge henrie beaucoup plus de dépenses
le budget des collectivités est
d'environ 250 milliards d'euros soit 30
milliards pour les régions 165 pour les
communes et enfin 30 pour les
départements alors où trouver des
économies là où il ya des économies très
importantes à faire c'est au niveau de
tout ce magma les communes les
intercommunalités les opc
les syndicats mix là il faut mettre les
mains dans le cambouis et commencer à
dire qui fait quoi et à empêcher qui est
un recouvrement et des compétences et
aussi ce qui est plus grave et qui coûte
très cher actuellement un recouvrement
des décideurs
les collectivités territoriales ont déjà
des budgets très serrés
l'état leur supprime 28 milliards
d'euros d'ici à 2017
si la fusion n'est pas une manne elles
devront trouver ailleurs les ressources
financières
alors on nous indique dans un premier
temps c'était une réforme pour faire des
économies puis maintenant on semble dire
qu on sait le gouvernement bien entendu
maintenant visiblement on fait moins
d'économies
est-ce que ça s'arrange envoie sur place
et on perd pas de temps avec cette
réforme et je pense qu'il faut réformer
voilà parce que pas seulement parce que
ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas réformé
ce serait pas un raisonnement en soi et
longer vos rêves mais non mais il y a
quand même
36000 communes plus de son département
avec mayotte avec 26 régions quand on à
le réformer en rajoutant les métropoles
moi je suis pour les métropoles mais pas
en l'air ajoutant par exemple ce qui a
été fait moi je le dis avec le gérard
collomb et michel mercier a lyon c'est
un bon exemple on a concentré sur la
métropole on a gardé le département
rural et probablement que c'est ça qu'on
aurait dû faire
moi je le porte depuis le début
métropolisation grande région maintient
des conseils généraux en rural donc vous
voyez hein je suis pas ratio
rationalisation intercommunalités
communes rurales donc peut-être
effectivement faire des grands ensembles
pour aider les communes rurales n'ont
pas à faire des économies mais à
rationaliser l'investissement parce que
c'est ça qui est important parce que ce
à quoi on a assisté depuis le début
depuis 30 ans et encore je rends grâce à
la loi defferre ans bravo mais tout de
même on a assisté alcan même une espèce
de compétition entre les territoires
qu'ils n'avaient pas un grand intérêt
l'histoire par exemple de notre dame des
landes et on est je suis désolé
le révélateur il ya 144 aéroports dans
notre pays est ce qu est ce qu on le
sait on est le pays qui a le plus
aéroports chacun veut son héros beau
c'était chez amazon industrielle était
une mesure pour faire des économies
c'est même pas dire une erreur c'est que
ça sera faut tout simplement à la fin
car on touche aux hauts fonctionnaires
territoriaux mais j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il y ait beaucoup de cela
ailleurs il y aura des coûts compliquée
par rapport aux fusions comme toujours
au moment des changements mais ce qui
compte et ça vraiment je suis conclut là
dessus c'est de préserver absolument le
fait que ce sont les collectivités
locales qui sont aujourd'hui le
principal investisseur public pour le
bien de nos concitoyens 75%
l'investissement public ce sont deux
activités locales et ça il faut
absolument maintenir cela c'est ça le
sujet essentiel de la réforme
territoriale vous approuve ce genre à
attendre et écouter ma question écouté
ma question en grande partie ce que dit
jean vincent placé
pourquoi vous expliquer que finalement
ici au sénat il puisse pas y avoir une
majorité un consensus autour d'une
organisation territoriale il finalement
on a l'impression laissée nathan
représente les collectivités
territoriales on est on un statut non
pas du tout la réforme elle ne commence
pas depuis la fin de ce printemps la
réforme
nous l'avons déjà fait en 2009 précédé
par un certain nombre de rapports
le rapport de claude belot plus personne
n'en parle travail en profondeur sur le
territoire est naturellement qu'il faut
faire évoluer l'organisation
territoriale la faire évoluer
c'est d'abord définir qui fait quoi le
sujet des compétences est majeur et la
nouvelle majorité
jean vincent placé n'a eu de cesse dans
la première année de majorité des faces
et moi je veux c'est qu'on nous
conformer métropole dont je suis à
l'aise dans la compétence que nous
avions défini qui fait quoi comme une
interco département région le 19
décembre 2013
c'est pareil à 10 ans le gouvernement
nous a proposé de supprimer la
spécialisation des compétences et voilà
qu'on y revient le premier des sujets
d'économie
c'est l'exercice de la compétence le
second des sujets qui représentent plus
de 30% des trente 30 plus 165 milliards
qui nous était présentée de dépenses
c'est notamment la masse salariale ont
des acteurs fonctionnaires dont et
contractuels territoriaux et voulaient
pas y toucher dans les pas du tout
m o un mot sur cette fonction publique
territoriale et son évolution
parce que c'est là que sont aussi une
partie des murs qu'on peut pas raconter
d'histoires aux françaises et aux
français
faire des économies demain c'est
rationaliser les compétences c'est aussi
maîtriser comme le dit la cour des
comptes le nombre de fonctionnaires et
d'agents territoriaux alors il faut
avoir le courage de le dire bien l'image
de l'homme à l'image du sénat ce vous
donner quand même l'image d'un sénat qui
ne veut pas bouger ça fait des petites
collision entre partis et qui vous le
sénat a voté en 2010 vous avez fait
preuve est fait pour d'autres côtés la
loi de 2010 qui prévoyait le conseiller
territorial mais lui qui siège à la
région et au département
la spécialisation des compétences lâché
wenger est bonne un casino s'est lancé
sur l'épaule sur vous dit vous n'avez
rien fait nous avons voté une loi on
vous dit pas c'est qu'il ya des
coalitions et rodez fait elle a été
défaite par la nouvelle majorité
uniquement par antisarkozysme ça je le
dis clairement c'est une faute contre
l'esprit après qu'on travaille sur une
nouvelle répartition territoriale
métropole département et notamment la
question de la ruralité de la proximité
n'oublions pas quand on parle de
ruralité que l'agriculture française est
la filière agroalimentaire reste l'un
des deux sièges sur notre pays c'est sa
raison qu'on n'en parle pas nous avons
une vision très parisienne jean vincent
placé est ce que vous avez peur que ce
débat autour de la réforme territoriale
vous fasse perdre le sénat en septembre
non non moi je suis pas dans ce type de
débat je pense que de façon de plus en
plus de plus en plus les gouvernements
les gouvernants des dirigeants ont du
mal à retrouver une forme de soutien
populaire voyez donc je suis pas très
optimiste pourquoi et pourtant on est
dans un moment aussi a besoin de ça on
est dans un pays en crise très difficile
et il faut pas se soucier julien pas
d'ailleurs par quinquennat unix dire
qu'il faut pas se soucier de la sa
réélection il faut faire des réformes
il faut faire des réformes non mais il
faut faire des réformes et là on a déjà
perdu deux ans - la réforme territoriale
lancée le grand objectif je la soutiens
je pense qu' on vient d'en parler et de
la fonction publique territoriale c'est
extrêmement important
la réforme fiscalité on s'est planté la
réforme européenne on n'est pas assez
volontariste enfin voyez des critiques -
premier sur le sénat moi je le dis je
veux pas polémiquer avec gérard larcher
pour lesquelles j'ai eu le plus grand
respect et y compris tant que président
du sénat moi je dis juste une chose
c'est que quand je vois son nom plus
excessivement de politique polémique
politicienne
le groupe des radicaux de gauche ici non
ils sont peut-être tous ruraux c'est moi
je trouve ça très sympathiques ils sont
surtout de tous des hommes ils ont tous
tous en cumul des mandats et les trois
sujets principaux sur lesquels se sont
manifestés depuis le début pas sur
l'économie pas sur l'écologie passe au
social il voulait pas trop la
transparence sur les patrimoines et sur
l'éthique en politique
ils sont pour le cumul des mandats et
enfin ils sont contre toute réforme
territoriale très sincèrement ça donne
une image incroyable 2 d'un groupe de la
majorité présidentielle arc-bouté comme
ça son conservatisme et ses traditions
au départ voilà non et c'est sûr que ça
nuit beaucoup à l'image du sénat dont
vous voyez je suis pas dans la langue de
bois ah oui oui non est ce que vous
estimez que la gauche a déjà perdu sénat
ou pas non mais aucune élection moi je
veux dire je peux rappeler de mauvais
souvenirs à gérard larcher
je pensais pas qu'on gagnerait à
prochaine fois voilà tant que quand la
dernière fois pardon
voyez ses traits à l'abstrait révélateur
pour 7 ans et pour le pire
une élection une élection n'est jamais
perdue ou gagnée d'avancé on fera le
maximum après le réalisme veut que
mathématiquement savait difficile mais
vous savez on va essayer de convaincre
les grands électeurs gérard larcher
jean-pierre raffarin famille aussi et je
vais vous dire sur tout ce qui est
important ici j'espère que pour paul
noté j'espère aussi que pour les
françaises et français qui nous
regardent et à le respecter et à
l'écouter il ya le débat est prêt
en plus qu'à l'assemblée nationale et ça
c'est important aussi en terme d'image
et moi je vous donnais juste un mot de
conclusion
quand je vois par exemple la séance des
questions au gouvernement à l'assemblée
nationale
j'ai envie des députés un jour ça
complètement surréaliste en réalité est
que ces matches et nous semblait ya le
respect il j'ai même vu des
parlementaires d'autres groupes
applaudir des questions dont il pensait
qu'il y avait un intérêt pour l'avenir
du pays et je crois que ça c'est bien
gérard larcher très rapidement pour
conclure sur ce point moi je voudrais
n'y est pas gagné je voudrais que que
les français fassent confiance au céda
dans ce que nous sommes parce que nous
sommes issus des élus locaux en qui ils
font confiance et je crois que au sénat
nous avons le devoir d'abord dé chacun
des dossiers pas simplement par clivages
politiques mais aussi en regardant quel
est l'intérêt du pays vous savez la
première préoccupation des français
c'est pas de savoir si on fera une
réforme territoriale de telle ou telle
manière c'est de garder de la proximité
c'est de garder les services publics en
même temps et d'avoir de la croissance
sur le territoire parce que la vraie
question celle qui hantent c'est celle
de l'emploi et celle de l'emploi c'est
aussi une des responsabilités que le
sénat doit pouvoir assumer parce que
représentant les territoires c'est sur
le territoire que se déroulera demain la
croissance ou la non croissance du pays
très rapidement un mickaël en avait un
des damiers sonore une dernière
interpellation de constitutionnalistes à
écouter oui il paraît que le sénat porte
malheur va écouter on va écouter
mathilde de films gays c'est une chose
utile et je dirais
hier provocatrices comme je le rappelle
souvent à mes étudiants que c'est
surtout une chambre qui porte malheur
qui est pour tous alors puisque
ensuite à des référendums négatifs sur
la question du sénat des personnalités
de premier plan ont dû démissionner j'ai
pensé que général de gaulle en 1964
donc le remonter encore plus loin le
premier projet de constitution de 1946
qui on se le rappelle
on sortait pas
le sénat et qui a été rejetée par les
électeurs et puis plus récemment un
ancien pour nos ministres d'une 2002
juste avant de le perdre l'élection au
premier tour des élections
présidentielles avait appelé à la
suppression du sénat ou le critiquer
fortement dans le monde et cela encore
bien porter mur est ce qu'être sénateurs
porte malheur alors comment conjurer le
mauvais oeil a vu tous mes lionel jospin
s'était planté entre guillemets quand
ils nous avaient traité d' anomalie
démocratique puisqu'il ya eu alternance
au sénat
le sénat c'est une institution qui vit
au rythme qu'il va passer chez
l'évolution des collectivités va
s'enclencher pour conclure ce qui
concerne maurice de talleyrand périgord
disait je porte malheur au gouvernement
qui me négligent auprès petit dire ça
aussi dit senna matière à réflexion je
me sens que mes recommandations pour
tous les gouvernements le sénat il a des
choses a dit nous pouvons donc conclure
en accord gérard larcher sur ce sujet
très important
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu aux
questions pour ceux du est décédé voilà
et vous pouvez retrouver cette émission
comme les quatre hommes et trois autres
duels de sénateur pour les élections
sénatoriales que nous avons enregistré
sur notre site publicsenat.fr ainsi que
toutes les émissions liées aux
sénatoriales du 28 septembre prochain
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis chez
nous avoir invités